hi everyone
uh thank you for uh joining me for this
webinar i am ajay i'm a senior bandmates
engineer
uh with kaijan specifically working in
our qdi services team
and uh today i'm going to give this
presentation
on uh some qdi uh qci
services that we provide uh in in
addition to our uh
core clinical platform such as qci
interpret
i'm to talk about the additional
services that we provide
with that platform to sort of uh
scale your clinical labs uh
throughput and even kind of enable a
seamless
end-to-end fast queue to your clinical
report
workflow uh so that
you have as less manual work
as possible and and you can quickly get
to your
final clinical report from from our
reporting solutions
so with that being said i'm going to
jump into
one of the most comprehensive
uh services uh before i jump into that
i'm just gonna talk about uh some of the
critical business issues and challenges
that uh typically uh clinical lab uh
faces so from a clinical lab perspective
uh
getting operational and generating
genetic testing reports in a timely and
cost
effective manner is is of the utmost
importance and you you don't want to
reference out your samples to another
lab
you are better off if you are able to
kind of process those
samples in in-house for example
typically setting up
analytics in-house is
can can be time consuming and and
costly because you might not have the
right infrastructure
typically next-generation sequencing
data
uh for the genetic tests uh seem to be
a like a lot in quantity does does
require some significant
uh infrastructure if you were to analyze
that in-house
so it it can become costly to set up an
infrastructure if you don't already have
one
uh to analyze that data and then once
you have the infrastructure set up
uh developing your analysis pipeline
such as the wherein calling pipelines
uh is is the next step and call and that
also is
is challenging uh to because it needs to
be customized uh based on the
assay that you're planning to run the
test that you're planning to run
so it does take a specific expertise and
and time
to develop that analysis pipeline uh
for for your test and then that that
expertise and that time
might not always be available uh
so with our services what we can enable
is we can enable a complete solution
uh for your lab that can take the raw
sequencing the ngs sequencing data
uh from from any platform it's black
platform agnostic like illumina iron
torrent
uh and then we can take you all the way
to a final clinical report uh
uh through through interpretation and
then sign
uh and and because we can enable this
seamless workflow almost automated
workflow there is a
very less manual effort uh that's
required here
uh and and that that that will help you
set up and release your test much
quicker and then also increase the
throughput of your
test so so the impact course is of
significant increase in profitability
and potentially
to process larger volume of samples if
you
do enable this service with us
and then you have reduced stress as you
have a single partner that is
a kaijen which has expertise on the
panels analytics interpretation
who will work with you in the long run
uh through through all these aspects
like right from
your second or not even like from your
panel to the
second analysis that is where i'm
calling
optimization and then even variant
reporting and and the final clinical
report
so we will work with you in all these
aspects
to to get you to your final clinical
report
from from your raw sequencing data
so so that being said i'm going to jump
into the most comprehensive
services solution that we provide to
clinical labs
typically is is our end-to-end
offering from from your raw data from
your raw fast q data
in qdi so from your ralph rsq data all
the way
to like a final clinical report in in
multiple different formats so
this is a very comprehensive services
offering
i said that that hits almost all
the aspects uh as from from your office
your data all the way to the
interpretation report
and then of course so there are
components there are service components
in
in this entire workflow that i'm going
to present
uh that of course you can even uh
kind of go for a la carte rather than
the whole solution but i'll come to that
a little later in the presentation so
there are
there are pieces of this that you can
choose to go for if you don't want to go
for the entire
workflow for example uh there are there
are a lot of
services pieces in here independent
pieces that you can also
uh choose to sign up for uh based based
on your
your needs so but i'll come to that a
little later in the presentation
so yeah starting out with the most
comprehensive offering here
from like the qdi services
clinical services that we provide
so assuming you you have a test that you
you're planning to launch you you have
your panel selected
and now you're you're looking at uh like
analytics for that panel in terms of
secondary analysis
uh that is variant calling and then
interpretation the final qci
interpretation so
in from the service side uh we can
enable
a whole end-to-end uh almost cloud-based
uh workflow
for for your for your test that will
take you all the way to
kyogen clinical insight interpretation
platform that we have and then even
produce
a report from that platform so
so typically if you as you can see in
this diagram
what people enable from the services
side is uh
we we will pick up your your raw
sequencing
data uh and that data can be from any
platform
any panel so it can be from a lumina
platform it can be from an
torrent platform uh it uh even
the panel that generated this this data
can be
a chiaseq panel that is a kylian panel
or it can even be a non-kyojin panel
like we have uh enabled this workflow
for
even a non-kaijen uh
like panel customers so you can even
enable this for a illumina panel or iron
torrent panel or a
agilent panel so what we'll do is we'll
take the rod sequencing data
from this panel from this platform so
and and then we will set up
a process where that data gets uploaded
to our
analytics uh engine so this analytics
engine
will be running a pipeline a variant
calling pipeline
that is that is uh that has been
optimized for
for your test and for your panel so
even before enabling this workflow we
will
build a specific a custom pipeline
analytics pipeline
for for your panel uh
and then then have it enabled on our
genomics
cloud engine that is our cloud
environment
and then once you start generating your
your sequencing data
the process will submit the sequencing
data
to this custom pipeline that we have
built for you
uh in on our cloud it is powered by aws
and then once the secondary analysis
results
are available then
we can work with your limbs provider for
example to
couple these results along with relevant
metadata for a particular sample in in
terms of
like the disease context for that sample
or or uh yeah the
the diagnosis that uh for that
particular sample so typically that that
information is uh
stored in a limbs or a list system and
and we will work with your limbs
provider even
uh to enable sort of uh
coupling that metadata information along
with the results
from our analytics pipeline and then
sending those results over
to our kaijan clinical insight platform
for variant interpretation
so we have enabled several such
workflows for customers where we have
worked with their limbs vendors to
integrate their lymph system to to this
uh workflow
uh by by using our application
programming interface that is apis
to then asset couple the
metadata information for a sample along
with
vcf uh or along with the variants that
are generated from our analytics
pipeline
uh and then kind of send that over uh to
our interpretation platform and then
even after weird interpretation in our
uh
kaijan clinical insight platform uh
the depending on the workflow that you
want to enable
there are capabilities of producing
custom pdf reports with your own design
own lab branding different
colors and different types of data that
can be presented on the report
that there are capabilities of exporting
data in
not just pdf but different formats such
as xml
so if you want your lim system to
generate the final report for example
and you just want qci to extract some
variant annotations
you can then extract those annotations
in a xml type of format that
is easily consumed by your lymph system
uh
or any report generation system that you
might be using
and and then uh
you can generate the report from your
from your own system so
yeah as you can see it's a whole
comprehensive end-to-end workflow here
with little to
no manual intervention uh the only
manual intervention might be that you
might want to manually review
uh the variance and their
classifications in the clinical insight
uh platform but apart from that this is
mostly hands off workflow
that that gets you from your raw
sequencing data
all the way to your final clinical
report
and as i said there are multiple
services
involved here is i said one is to build
the
uh customized workflow
for your panel uh and then having it
enabled on this uh
our genomics cloud engine here and then
the other aspect is to kind of work with
your limbs provider
uh so that uh correct integrations are
built
into our clinical institute platform uh
and then even within the
clinical inside platform depending on
how
you want it we can set up your set your
pdf report with different designs
different uh types of data that can be
presented
or or you can set you up with just xml
style export
from from the platform which you can
export the
annotations and data for the variants
and and then
build build your your own report so
this is a very comprehensive offering i
said that uh
takes you all the way can take you all
the way to your
final clinical report
so
having having presented this then now
i'm going to go
a little more into the ala carte
offerings uh that i that i mentioned so
as i said uh the uh this is a very
comprehensive offering
but if if for example you already have
your
your own variant calling pipeline that
you you have developed or are
comfortable with
uh but just need uh the integrations
with your lymph system
uh for for high throughput submissions
uh to our interpretation platform and
just need various interpretations
uh we can enable that or or if you
just need like a pdf report a nice pdf
report
with your branding and and design we can
enable
that uh if you want like a customized
xml export with uh different uh data
points
uh we can enable that so
there are there are multiple uh a la
carte offerings that you can go for
if you don't want to go for like this
whole uh comprehensive
service offering here uh yeah before i
jump into that i
have one one quick uh thing
to reiterate that this is platform
agnostic you can enable this for
for any panel any any sequencing
platform
uh and then the other thing being this
is mostly a cloud-based
workflow so you don't have to maintain
any any sort of servers or hardware
uh in-house because uh
the secondary analysis engine is also it
is running on
our our cloud instance the amazon s3
instance
uh and and then even kaiju clinical
insight is a cloud-based
uh software so for this whole workflow
you you don't have to maintain any any
sort of uh
hardware or very minimal hardware uh
locally
and now i will kind of move into
more of the a la carte offerings
so i said if you if you don't want
kind of if you already have a secondary
analysis platform that you
you have access to and are not
comfortable with for your panel
that calls the variants and and you just
want
the variant interpretation from qci and
are looking for a high throughput
submissions to the platform and
and exporting data from the platform uh
instead of uh
low throughput upload through the ui one
by one
sort of a process then
we do have uh very comprehensive apis
application programming interfaces
uh into qci interpret uh that we provide
consultation for
so that your lymph system or list
systems
uh can take advantage of these
application programming interfaces
uh and then couple your variants along
with the
relevant metadata for that sample
so depending on the workflow whether
you're uh
trying to get up like a somatic test up
and running or a germline test up and
running
most of the sample based metadata that
might be required for variant variant
interpretation
such as uh like for a germline panel
if it's like a carrier screening if the
you might be interested in specific
uh indications or or the
german diseases you you might want to
focus on
uh all that information for a sample is
stored
mostly in the lymph system uh for
example if for a somatic overflow
uh the diagnosis is is an important
piece of information that is required
for variant interpretation
and that piece of information is
typically stored in a lens or a list
system
and then we will work with either limbs
vendors
commercial third-party limits vendors or
even if it's an internal
in-house system that you have developed
uh we we will work with
the developers of your system to enable
uh like an end-to-end workflow where you
submit your variants along with the
relevant metadata to the qci platform
and automatically you can even export
out
variant annotations in in the format of
your choice
such as xml or pdf and then you can
export that data
back into your limb system for a whole
end-to-end uh workflow
so we have already done a lot of
successful
integrations with third-party lims
vendors
uh and one's advantage with this is once
the integration is built
uh then then typically so it's a
one-time effort so
uh it's a minimal effort it's a one-time
effort the apis are
quite comprehensive so uh
so we have partnered with not not
officially partner but we have
worked with many third-party commercial
limbs vendors to build integrations into
qci so that uh to enable
uh like high-throughput uh less manual
intervention
end-to-end workflow for for our
customers
we have also worked with uh in-house
systems
uh systems that were developed in-house
by the customers we have also
successfully
interacted with the like in-house
development teams
to build uh api integrations into into
qci so
this kind of gives you a seamless
end-to-end workflow
once you get your vcf or once you get
your variant calls
from from your secondary analysis or
wherein calling pipeline that they are
using
this kind of a service can pick you up
from there
and then take you all the way to the
clinical report so
uh you you won't so as
i if you remember if i presented in in
the whole comprehensive solution
uh this one yeah you can just go for the
api integration
uh consultation service kind of that we
provide
so kind of moving on uh
after your upload into the qci platform
we can also set up custom variant
reporting policies uh that
can help you to report variants
automatically and and save you a lot of
manual effort to go through each and
every variant
and kind of manually report that variant
out
to be on your final clinical report
so there so once you upload the variants
into the qci platform either via the
apis that i described before
or even if you have enabled our whole
comprehensive service offering
once you upload the variants into qci
and we can set up automated reporting
policies
uh using uh that this is a service that
we can provide
is to to then assess those variants
based on those uh
based on the reporting policy and the
reporting policy
will will be created based on on what
you want it to be so based on on your
labs reporting rules we we can
implement that in qci and and have uh
the variance automatically reported uh
and then you can just do a quick review
of those
uh and and then that that kind of solves
that saves you a lot of manual effort to
uh assess or go to each and every
variant of each and every variant
examples of reporting policies
is typically for example in
qci we implement the acmg rules
but for example in europe most of the
labs follow the acgs
rules instead of acmg they are slightly
different uh so for some of those labs
we created custom reporting policies
that implement the ecgs rules instead of
the acmg rules
some of the clinical labs
report variants only below or above a
certain allele fraction
so we can kind of implement those
custom rules of our custom rules for a
lab
such that variance below a certain
allele fraction won't even get reported
so
you you don't have to review those
variants because your labs protocol is
to not look at variance below central
view fraction
for example and and that will save you a
lot of manual effort
uh we can we can have variant
assessments
uh expire after a certain period so many
of the labs once they assess a
particular variant uh
if they see that variant again in like a
period of six months they like to report
it the exact same way
but after six months they want to do
like a re-review of that variant to make
sure that
there's been no extra content that that
might change the classification of the
variant for example
so we can we can have the custom
policies where your assessments
expire after a certain period of time
and these are these are just some of the
examples uh that i've outlined here but
uh this this can essentially be
customized uh
based on your your needs so if your lab
has a set of protocols that it applies
for for a variant assessment uh
many of those protocols can be are like
programmed into these reporting policies
and and then that that does save you a
lot of
manual work and for many of the samples
you
it will take you a minute to generate a
clinical report final clinical report
for a particular
sample rather than having having to
assess a bunch of 50 60 variants
that that might take a lot of time
so these are the reporting policies
after the reporting policies uh now now
we come
to the data export part of it because
say once you have once you are ready to
kind of publish a report
uh what kind of services should we
provide in that
area so for
for reporting out of the qci platform
uh we do provide a lot of services we do
provide
a custom pdf design
for for your lab and and that design is
is
completely flexible in terms of layout
in in terms of design in terms of
language in terms of content
so for example there are a couple of
examples in this slide as you can see
bb even through custom services can
support
languages as complex as mandarin arabic
so we have varied language support
through services
uh to extend the capabilities of the qci
platform so
you can imagine the the amount of
customization that can be done here
uh the the platform is very flexible
so you you can have a report
like a final clinical report with your
lab branding with the design of your
choice
and we can enable that and then even the
data that is presented on the report is
is customizable
so again that that is based on on your
choice so we we work with you closely
to produce a report uh that that
suits your needs and and many of our
customers
uh the the reports generated from our
platform
can go directly or do go directly to
to their uh customers or
in some cases even patients because the
qci platform is
a hipaa compliant completely secure
platform
so you can even send us phi data such as
the patient name or or any data that is
uh
that is considered phi and and
uh you can have it shown on your final
clinical report so many customers do
take advantage
of this services that we provide and and
for them
the report coming out of qci is kind of
the final report that goes to
to like their uh customers or our
patients so
uh this is uh this is one of the very
popular service offerings that we have
because as you can see it's very very
flexible in terms of what
we can do here for your report and and
this
i i presented about the pdf report but
we
do have the capability to export the
data from the platform in
in multiple other other formats such as
so pdf is not the only one
but we we do have an xml output or
xml export that you can take advantage
of so if you do have your own pdf
reporting engine
existing pdf reporting existing
reporting engine
that and you just want to export
the data from qci and you want to feed
that data to your
your own uh the system that does that
generates the final data uh that is
possible because xml
is a very flexible export format
so you can export the qci annotations in
an xml format
and then you can parse that xml to
extract
uh the information or annotations that
you're interested in
and and then you you can feed those to
your own reporting system
and generate reports from there so this
xml
output is also very flexible we can
[Music]
add more data points to it uh depending
on your needs
we can pivot the structure uh depending
on your needs
so based on on that way
so yeah i said uh we
similar to different styles of pdf
reports
we can also develop different formats of
the
xml reports or exports
so for example we can add extra
customized
content to your xml export or we can
change or pivot the structure of the xml
export based on
what your system needs or or what's the
most uh
suitable for for for your needs so
this is also a very flexible export that
is used by
many of our customers as that who have
their own reporting engine
or or who generate reports from their
limb system so this is a very uh
flexible format for that
uh so this goes back again into uh
the the api integrations where any
system
can extract this uh output from from the
qci
platform in an xml format and then
use that data to to generate your report
and then you can even export the pdf
report pdf style report from from the
api
and then save it back to your system of
record
so there is a lot of lot of flexibility
here in in terms of what what can be
done
to to customize the output
so with that that is kind of the
overview
of all the services uh that we do
provide related to our uh
qci or qdi uh platform uh
for clinical services so as you can see
it's a very comprehensive
service offering i said you you can
enable the whole
fast queue to your clinical report
workflow
but not just that uh depending on your
need
uh you you can avail any of the services
a la carte uh depending depending on on
what you are looking for and what is
your labs needs so for example if you
have your second analysis pipeline set
and are just looking for high throughput
variant
uh reporting and annotation through the
qci platform
we can enable that through the apis if
you are looking for
just a very nice clinical report
with a design of your choice that is
doable
if you are looking for an xml style
export that is doable
uh so there is a lot of flexibility that
uh the services that we provide that can
can bring
to your clinical lab and then eventually
this will
help you to kind of streamline your your
uh
test and and then will help you scale
your test
whenever needed thank you very much
you